içinden geçmek yerine
Onu içinde
çok kültürlü
[Müzik]
olmak
Y
[Müzik]
görev düzenleme
Hayır
[Müzik]
bacaklarının dikkati
herhangi
[Müzik]
ve
refah
ve her zaman
bir şey geliyor
ve
[Müzik]
yapmak istiyoruz
ona
[Müzik]
ve Tanrı
o
[Müzik]
Hayır
ve bu kadar
[Müzik]
ve
anlamamak
Y
ilk
[Müzik]
Iyi aşk
Hadi
bir kere daha
Y
bir kere
[Müzik]
ve
kullandıklarına bağlılar ama hiçbir şeye değil
[Müzik]
bu bilinmiyor
kıyı şeritleri
[Müzik]
Evet
D
ile
Y
olsa bile
açıkçası daha fazlası olmalı
yürüme
Y
o zaman karar verdik
[Müzik]
ve para
Evet
kendisi
Eğer öyleysen
[Müzik]
hayır
ya da değil
s
ve inkar edenler
[Müzik]
Youtube'da
Temizlemek
[Müzik]
yasak
sen yaşıyorsun
farzedelim
[Müzik]
Yas tutmak
ve sen
Y
vardır
[Müzik]
Bence
D
Y
[Müzik]
Ben
belki gerçekten başka bir şey değil
Bence
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Evet
[Müzik]
Benim şehrimde
mevcut [ __ ]
Ben
Evet
[Müzik]
ve şu
Beğendim
[Müzik]
Y
Bence
[Müzik]
emlak fırıncıları
şimdi temiz oturuyoruz
ve görünmek
[Müzik]
anlamı
hatta daha fazla
[Müzik]
yolda
ama varlar
Ne
Y
iyi
[Müzik]
bir tek
bir başkası tek başıma şarkı söylediği için şanslı
geri gelmek şüpheli bir hayattır
[Müzik]
ve
Manuel uzayacak
verebilecek bir kişi
İstiyorum
bir tek
[Müzik]
herkes
çeşitli ölçeklere ulaşmak
[Müzik]
ile
çalı ve hala çevrimiçiler
atış
belirli kabilelere
[Müzik]
ne
Ancak
ve şu
Artık
akla
[Müzik]
bugün
D
nihai enerji
ona
[Müzik]
m
ve
teklif aslında ortağım için bir nokta
doğru
[Müzik]
Teşekkürler
Evet evet
merhaba diyelim
Kapa çeneni
D
puan
biz ilişkiliyiz
ve eğer istersen
Ancak
x
[Alkış]
diğer koç diğer
başka bir vizyon
seni seviyorum
D
1 2007
[Alkış]